hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to guts and glory a game
that's supposed to be a lot like happy
wheels but in 3d which means that
there's going to be lots of blood and
body parts flying around screams of pain
as far as the ear can hear it's a fun
time all around and you guys wanted me
to play it so I'm going to do just that
a terrible tutorial just real tractor
Jesus baby do I look like the kind of
guy that needs a tutorial no I've been
playing happy wheels for a long time so
I'm gonna play no weight points just
right to the finish with anyway you get
the fun delano course that sounds fun oh
the hell is that
John Jimmy Earl and the yang family well
there's only ready okay know what was my
name's Jeremy and Jackson Jehovah and
Jeremiah I don't know Jeffery and Jude
John Donovan Donovan is that netwo god
hi
oh jeez this isn't exactly uh deadly yet
but I imagine the deadliness comes later
excuse me
oh whoa hey excuse me pardon me
kid did you chicken arrow in the knee oh
no oh no oh god okay Wow
okay can't get out of the wheelie well
there we go that's quite a lot of arrows
oh we're not dead yet so I guess we're
pretty okay I can keep going oh well I
guess this days not done son I guess
we're going into town alright it was
boring warmup okay why is there a cannon
on a roof all right John Jimmy ready no
no I'm not I'm not ready okay oh nothing
like a little whiplash for a son to get
by great start on your childhood there
kid nice sick moves okay well I guess I
guess that's closed off to school
let me just crumple up and remember all
my terrible memories oh my for childhood
I can't stop crying
what a [ __ ] hang on
they're such a successful ding and now
right did John John John V jet Jam Joe
Jimbo
JimBob JimBob and Jimbo okay Wow these
controls are a little wonky a little bit
hey watch where you're shooting there
you [ __ ] hey that almost probably Oh
landmine oh that's bad I should have
known about that Oh God I mean my torso
obviously in pieces over there but my
son oh [ __ ] it's good God actually look
at the ground this time would be oh
that's that's much better
Oh avoid them Oh what happened
Punk it's like made of plastic I guess I
guess once again I was crud I was
crippled by the emotional burden of my
teenage years oh man hold it together I
said hold it together goddamn it you're
falling apart of the scenes or maybe I
am I think I think my arm just turned
into one big middle finger so I can give
it to the world as I ride by alright I
guess unless you didn't even blow us up
we just fell apart
oh that neck that giblet on me yeah nice
try it again a little less [ __ ] only
pay attention that's the long and the
short of that yeah oh yeah come on Jack
a boy and job job job as a job Oh jump
Jimbo and bow
we did warm-up whiplash well I already
gave my who already gave my son whiplash
so maybe this Wingo be so good what whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa I wasn't ready
hey are those laws do I need avoid those
guys again with less suck which I have
ample amounts i've got equal amounts of
sucking win why
all right this time with the even less
suck man just need to control their so
janky this is like instantaneously
blunt-force trauma from the jerking
motion yeah well bossun the rest of it
okay this time not stupid one flip is
all we need Oh God okay no roll kids
that's your own rule sorry kid I mean it
god damn it it's so hard
there's like some self correcting this
to it like a little bit not a lot but a
little bit just enough okay this is the
one who's won Jen Jen Jen Jennifer
Jamison got that hook well bye
alright so that's pretty good industrial
power cannons cannons on Main Street
look
before crossing the street I don't think
that's gonna help us I don't think
that's gonna help us at all I don't
think it helped him I don't think it's
gonna help us all right
I'm assuming you're John and I'm Jimmy I
don't like the name let's just take a
break son don't worry about it I know
you're cowering in fear but we'll be
fine
all right so oh that tip I probably
should have read it it's the cannons on
Main Street well okay then
good god my goodness gracious okay we
got this he's already dead oh well take
him again oh okay all right Oh on the
open circuit then I'll go
okay very good I killed myself John I
ended it all out of fear and it just
turned out worse him what's so scary
that's so scary
that's so scary the trick is to ride a
row god [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah miss me miss me miss me yeah
whoa that did nothing yes so the problem
is I keep getting slowed down by the
curbs so I gotta find a way to get [ __ ]
I got slowed down by the mailbox there I
gotta go I gotta find a way [ __ ] Wow
there's got to be a way to get over that
curb easier man it's not easy it's not
it's not easy it's really not easy like
trying to I was on the ground [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh man these controls are like
they're they're very selective on what
they're not what is with the
inconsistent what am i doing don't don't
don't I'm dead I'm dead I've become one
with my bike yeah it's it's very like
inconsistent on how much it wants to
turn okay oh jeez I'm not gonna make
this a bike it's it really is
inconsistent like I don't know why it's
inconsistent though it doesn't make
sense that it is inconsistent cuz I'll
turn like that and I've turned like that
before and I hit the wall whoa okay I'm
over here now okay I don't know okay
fine I didn't want it to fall over and
die like an idiot oh they're still
shooting at me well it's probably bad I
should have read that tip at the
beginning the tip at the beginning
probably had something that's gonna get
a lot easier hot-diggity I did it I did
it
Wow extreme jump alright I'll do an
extreme jump oh hello John and Jimmy we
can do this I don't know how but we can
do this oh well this don't seem good
which way am I supposed to go this is
quite the jump it's extreme dare I say
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy
woah okay did we make it oh we were so
close okay we can do this I just wasn't
going down the right section of the hill
before I got caught up by my own stupid
death yeah oh you knew this ah okay okay
okay okay okay yeah well that's not
exactly what I Oh
we did it I mean we didn't do the last
part of the jump but I counted I can't I
count partial credit for me okay
meat-grinder
this is the hardest one on here I mean
that cannon ones it's pretty hard just
because it control ah I am NOT the most
dedicated at this and I don't think that
I'm going to be trying very hard to win
it okay I was about to say so far so
good
jeez first try winning Oh
there's land mines oh I didn't realize
that oh I'm stupid
no no no not not the cone scoots good
all over again yeah Oh miss me oh I'm
just gonna take a breather here while we
get resituated miss me what happened God
for some reason it seems like it's
farther away than it actually is it's so
weird okay
okay all right we're good Wow Wow Wow
that hurts a lot look at me look at me
all those years of happy wheels have
really paid off okay so that was the
hardest one so that is guts and glory
thank you everybody so much for watching
there's a lot of potential here the
controls like the thing about happy was
is that the controls in the game are
they're very tight it's got great game
feel in this one it feels like it's
intentionally wonky to make it funnier
which it does but also it doesn't make
it like a tighter game you know the
controls aren't as responsive but still
for early alpha this is really good like
this has got a lot of potential here
there's just more that could be put into
it and a lot more expanded and then a
custom level creator and it's good to go
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought
the Hunter has become without egg